- I'm going to be a princess!
All my life I wanted to be a princess
and look how nice, you are.
You're going to make me a princess.
(royal music)
I had older brothers, so I was always
playing with the boys a lot.
I was a tomboy.
- I always dreamed about Prince Charming.
I'm still waiting for him. (laughs)
- Well, my husband was my
Prince, so ... (laughs)
- I grew up during the war,
but I was not a princess, I was tough.
- I can still remember my brother, Mikey,
taking me to see Snow White,
in 1937.
- I saw Frozen and I really
got a kick out of it.
I watched it with my grandkids.
- You're going to make me look Cinderella,
or like the Princess Cinderella?
- [Male] The Princess Cinderella.
- Princess Cinderella.
- [Male] Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm excited, too.
I love a makeover and I
love being a princess.
I could show my great-granddaughter.
She'll be thrilled to see
Grandma as a princess.
- We were young once. (laughs)
- What do we really know
about this Snow White?
Is she really pure and like Ivory soap?
Or is she a (bleep)-ing (bleep)?
God knows what she's doing
with those dwarfs. (laughs)
- Going to the ball
and meeting the Prince.
That's the best part.
- You got Happy, he's
happy, why is he happy?
She's giving him blow jobs, probably.
- When I came here, when I arrived here,
I did not know the language.
I did not know anyone, I
went to sleep at night,
and I was crying before
I went to sleep. (laughs)
It's very, very different when you know
you're going to another
country in many years,
then you get used to them.
- Then, when I met my husband,
I don't know we hit it off,
but it took a long time
'til we started to go out.
Everybody wanted to know
why I waited so long.
Every other day we saw each
other, or he'd call me.
It was really, by nine
months, we were married.
- I think it's harder for
girls growing up today.
They just grow up too fast.
More pressure, and then they
can get in trouble right away.
- And we were easy to
compromise in those days.
You have to learn to get along.
Fight, but get back together.
Everytime I see my
great-granddaughter and her friends,
they're always dressing up with costumes
and they idolize shows
like Frozen and Cinderella.
You could see it, they
loved to be princesses.
It's a different world.
We weren't that much into it
because I don't think we had
the movies and the
Disney stuff, in our day.
- Oh!
- Ah!
- Oh my God!
- Is that me? (laughs)
- Oh my goodness, oh my goodness!
- I see my eyes, I look like I'm strong
when I looked in the mirror.
- I feel wonderful!
I feel like I'm great.
- Being a princess is so much fun.
The make up, the wig was fun.
I always wanted to be a blonde,
now I know what it looks like!
- We forget that we're old.
(laughs)
We're having a good time.
- Every girl is a princess,
they don't have to be dressed up.
- Keep on dreaming of
princesses and princes because,
hey, if you dream hard enough
and you wish hard enough,
they say your wishes will come true.
(foreign language)
- Mwah!
- I love to have more Disney
stuff because of the fantasies.
- I am a (bleep)-ing princess!
Who could take that
away from me right now?
No one.